Lee Bollinger: Thank you very much, Mr.
President. I would also like to
recognize some special guests that we
have. First lady Hero Ahmed is here.
Please recognize her. I believe your son
has also joined us here, and his name
is Qubad Talabany. We have the Minister
of State for Women's Affairs, Ms. al-
Shakly, the Minister of Labor, Mr. *Sali,
and the Minister of Technology, Ms.
Putros. We would now like to open the
floor for questions. Please go. I'd like to
give priority to Columbia students.\
Casey Barnett: Good morning. My name is
Casey Barnett. I am a student with
the business school here at Columbia.
I'm also the director of Cam-Ed, a
research and training Institute in Southeast
Asia. Your Excellency, you
mentioned that the Iraqi Constitution
is the best in the region. Yet, Article7 of
the
Constitution forbids Ba'ath Party members
from becoming part of the political
system. Now, most people became Ba'ath
party members to go to college or get
a job. Wouldn't it be smarter for your
government to focus on the leaders of the
Ba'ath Party, rather than the rank and
file?
Lee Bollinger: We also should, take this
occasion, you can just lineup behind
the microphones to ask questions.
President Jalal Talabani: This is not
true. Not all Ba'athists are prevented from
participating. Only the criminals and
special rank of Ba'athists are prevented.
But the big majority of them are permitted.
They are considered as Iraqis. They
can participate in the democratic process.
And even many of them are still in
jobs, in universities, in schools, in
departments, in administration, and only who
are prevented from that, those who committed
crimes according to law.
Lee Bollinger: Next question.
Garth Stewart: Sir, my name is Garth Stewart,
and I'm a general studies
student here at Columbia. And, I was in
the Third Infantry Division in 2003 and I
was a very active participant in the liberation
of Iraq. And I have to say--
Lee Bollinger: I'm sorry. Let me just
ask, put the microphone up so that you
can be heard more clearly.
Garth Stewart: Is this all right? Is this
acceptable if I just bend my head a little
bit?
Lee Bollinger: That's good. That's good.
Garth Stewart: I was in the Third Infantry
Division, an active participant in the
liberation of Iraq. And I have to say,
it's an honor to hear you speak here today,
sir. My question is, in your speech, you
referred to a new Iraq. And I wanted to
know, do you ever plan on seeking some
sort of reform in the Middle East as it
concerns other governments that aren't
so enlightened as what Iraq is
becoming?
President Jalal Talabani: Of course. For
this reason, many of our neighbors
are very, are not happy and satisfied
because a democratic, federal, stable Iraq
will inspire all people of Middle East
to free themselves from dictatorship and to
enjoy democracy. For that, I think you;
when you're in Iraq, observe that many
neighbors are not satisfied with the liberation
of Iraq or having democracy and
democratic rights in Iraq.
Manal Alam: Hi. Mr. President, my name
is Manal Alam, and I'm a student in
the engineering school. What will it take
in the future for Iraq to have a separate
political identity not linked to the United
States?
President Jalal Talabani: I think we are
an independent country, and Iraqi
people are proud to be independent and
we always struggle to be an
independent country, but we are in need
to a kind of core operation and alliances
in this global of we are so far living
in it, and this globalization is demanding
that
countries must look kind of cooperation
and coordination among them.
Lee Bollinger: Next question.
Cham Laden: Mr. President, my name is
Cham Laden, I'm a journalism
student here. And as I understand it,
you have the very admirable policy of not
signing execution warrants which Iraq
courts pass up to your office and delegate
this duty to a deputy. And I also understand
that this is because the Democratic
patriotic alliance of Kurdistan is obliged
under treaties you signed not to endorse
the death penalty. I think that's wholly
admirable, but I was wondering if you
thought it was a problem, or set a poor
precedent for the president of a sovereign
country of Iraq to be bound by regional
obligations, not to fulfill sections of his
office. Thank you.
President Jalal Talabani: Well, you know,
we are in Iraq now enjoying
democracy. We have different parties and
groups from Left, extreme Left to
extreme Right. Of course, different attitudes.
I am, as a lawyer, I signed an
international appeal against the death
penalty. And I'm respecting my signature.
For that, I am able, (applause) even I
said, if I was one day obliged to choose
between my principles and the post, I
will leave the post and keep my, protect my
principles. (applause) I know that perhaps
the next president will not be in the
same way and the same kind of thinking.
But it's my belief, and I cannot deny
my signature.
Lee Bollinger: Next question.
Patrick Luhem: Hello, Mr. President, my
name is Patrick Luhem. I'm a student
of Japanese literature here in the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences and I
wanted to thank you for your speech and
also welcome you to Columbia. During
your speech, you spoke about the kindness
and generosity of American troops.
And, with
that attitude, I was wondering how you interpret
an event like what
happened at Abu Ghraib.
President Jalal Talabani: Yeah, that was,
in Abu Ghraib something was very
bad happened, that some American soldiers,
simple soldiers violated the human
rights. But I'd like to remind you, Abu
Ghraib was a prison in Iraq when
thousands and thousands of Iraqis were
executed. It was a prisoner of tens of
thousands of Iraqis visited this prison,
and suffered worse kind of torture and
violating of human rights. For that, of
course, we condemn what happened
against Iraqis, because we want to have
the human rights everywhere in Iraq,
and human rights must be respected by
Americans, Iraqis, everyone. But, when
Iraqis remember prison of Abu Ghraib,
they are remembering thousands and
thousands of the martyrs who were killed
in that prison.
Lee Bollinger: Next question.
Marin Dunnaheim: Mr. President, my name
is Marin Dunnaheim. I'm Masters
of Laws student from Ireland. In light
of the Constitutionalization and the
problems that have sewn in Iraq, what
is the possibility of the complete
secularization of Iraq in light of the
role that religious law plays and religious
diversity plays in Iraq?
President Jalal Talabani: Well, we couldn't
reach a secular state, hundreds
person (inaudible). There was a kind of
compromise, as I told you in my speech.
There is of course we have strong Islamic
parties. There were, even some of
them were asking for an Islamic Republic.
For example, we couldn't reach
agreement with a group of Sunni Arabs
about the article, which says that Islam is
a source for laws. They insisted that
it must be the main source of all laws. We
refused it. We tried to reach a kind of
compromise that we could in the same
time, respect the democratic principles
and respect Islam as the religious of the
majority of Iraq. Of course it's respecting
other religions, like Christianity, like
Azadis, like Sabbis and others which
mentioned in this Constitution.
Lee Bollinger: Next question.
Shirley Shavit: Hello, Mr. President.
My name is Shirley Shavit. I'm the
director of an international department,
and biggest women's organization in
Israel. First of all, it was a great honor
to hear you and to listen to what you said.
And I'm very concerned and would like
to ask your attitude regarding the state of
Israel, regarding the future coexistence
with Iraq. And I think we have a lot in
common regarding our concern for world
democracy as well as the Al Qaeda
threat to the whole world.
Thank you very much.
President Jalal Talabani: Well, thank
you for question. And we are in Iraq
committed to our member and active member
and founder member of the
league, Arab League. We are part of the
Arab world. Iraq participated on all the
summit, Arab summits. The last one, which
was in Beirut, decided that a
doctorate, proposal, presented by then
president, now King Abdullah of Saudi
Arabia, according to this proposal, there
is some kind of promise if Israel will
respect all resolutions passed by the
United Nations and recognize the existence
of a peaceful Palestinian state. The Arab
countries will normalize relation with
Israel, and will have full kind of contracts
with them. It's now up to Israeli people
and Israeli government to decide to accept
this proposal of King Abdullah, and
then I think everything will be normal
and open.
Lee Bollinger: Yes.
Carmack MacGee: I'm Carmack MacGee.
I'm his master student at the
school of International and Public Affairs.
(speaks Arabic) Columbia.
President Jalal Talabani: (speaks Arabic).
Carmack MacGee: Being Middle Eastern,
specifically from Lebanon, I just want
to let everyone know that any change in
the Middle East is better than the status
quo. So some people who argue--at this
point in time--so some people who
argue about whether the U.S. should have
gone in or out, I think the change was
very important. However, I do have a concern.
In your speech, you said a
repeated number of times that you are
killing and capturing the terrorists. I was
just wondering, these people strive and
breed on the blood of their martyr
brothers. Do you think that by killing
and capturing these terrorists, you will be
solving the problem of insurgencies? Because
I find that this is only addressing
the symptom of terrorism rather than the
radical cause of terrorism. So what
measures are being done by the Iraqi government
to address social welfare and education?
President Jalal Talabani: Yes. Well, killing
is not enough. But don't forget, we
are killing those terrorists in defense
of ourselves. They are attacking us, and we
are killing them. This is a very important
point you must take it in consideration.
When they are coming for example to occupy
a town, we are not ready to
surrender to them, we are going to resist,
to liberate the town, and we are killing
those who are trying to impose their rule
by force on the people. This is one.
Second, we believe that there must be
a comprehensive plan for facing terrorism.
This plan must be political, economic,
media, public opinion, relation with
diplomacy, many things here. And I think
those who came, terrorists in Iraq are
different groups. Some different, some
groups are from Al Qaeda, and
fundamentalist Islamists who came and
declared the order of annihilation. They
openly say it.
And statesmen, that are killing all shades,
and consider all shades out of Islam.
And also, they're killing all Kurdists.
Because they are allies of the United States
of America. Well, a group coming to declare
the war of annihilation, what do you
want for us? Maybe we got to (inaudible).
This is one. Second, second, as you
said, any change in Middle East is very,
very important. And especially,
democratic change is very important. It
will change the Middle East. And those
who are afraid from new Iraq, they are
afraid from democracy and from
democratization in Middle East.
Andrew Monaghan: Mr. President, it's an
honor to have you here today. My
name is Andrew Monaghan and I'm with the
School of International and Public
Affairs. We learn from the American experience
as the oldest democracy in the
world that one of the true potential threats
of the federalist system is Civil War.
What assurances do you give the world
that Iraq can become a true federalist
democracy that will stay together? Thank
you.
President Jalal Talabani: Well, it depends
on the will of Iraqi people. It's also
mentioned in the Constitution that Iraqi
people, through their free will, decide if
they want to have regional governments,
kind of, we think that Federation, with
democracy are necessary for building a
multi-nation country, and without
Federation and democracy, it's impossible
to imagine a united, strong Iraq, with
all these different nationalities and
religions, etcetera.
Rachel MacMillan: Thank you. Mr. President,
my name is Rachel MacMillan. I
am in the Columbia College. One of the
main reasons that President Bush gave
us for going to war in Iraq and for Operation
Iraqi Freedom was the allegation of
nuclear weapons, which we now know didn't
exist. Now, of course, in Iran and
North Korea, we see large nuclear weapon
arsenals being developed as well.
Do you think that if it was a basic human
rights issue, that we would have gone
to Iraq in the first place, or was that
lie actually needed to garner international
support and attention?
President Jalal Talabani: Well, I think
there were mass destruction arms.
According to our information, our own
information, there was massive chemical
weapons, which was used against Kurdish
people in Halajan, against Iranians
and against South of Iraq. And there was
also, in the (inaudible), biological
weapons also. Now we are discovering graves,
for example, that contain the
children between six to, one to six year,
some other six to 12, some 12 to 18.
We think that there was a kind of exercise
of the chemical and the biological
weapons. We were sure that there were
chemical weapons and there were
biological weapons. But they could hide
them.
You know, Iraq is a big country. This
is one. The second, I think liberating 27
million Iraqis and building a democratic
center in Middle East was deserving to
be, to participate in this war of liberation.
And don't forget that this is a tradition
of American people. America participated
in the Second World War, first World
War, in Asia, liberating Afghanistan and
Belkan, in many places. That's the
glorious people of the world. They have
their own responsibility to pay the price
of it. Although I'm sorry for all kinds
of American casualties.
Lee Bollinger: Yes.
Student: President, I'm international
student in the School of Engineering and,
from Turkey. So, I wonder what you exactly
meant in the beginning of your
speech with Kurdistan?
President Jalal Talabani: Pardon?
Student: What you meant exactly in the
speech of, in the beginning of your
speech, as Kurdistan.
President Jalal Talabani: Kurdistan is
a country. I didn't create it. God created
it. A few in Turkey denying it. It doesn't
mean that it's not existing. This even at
the time of command pressure (inaudible)
was recognize that, go back to the first
building of Turkish National Assembly,
you will see on the wall, the list of military,
Kurdistan military. This country is now
a part of it in Iraq. This part of Iraq is
officially recognize it. We have a regional
government of Kurdistan, and this
original, we have also a National Assembly
of Kurdistan that we are recognizing
in Iraq. We don't want to interfere in
your own affairs. If you don't want to
recognize it, it's up to you. But we have
Kurdistan as a part of Iraq.
Lee Bollinger: Yes?
Nate Jennings: Welcome, Mr. President.
My name's Nate Jennings. I'm an
undergraduate student in the engineering
school. You spoke a little bit about the
Constitution in your speech. And I was
wondering if you could address what the
major impediments are to having some kind
of consensus. I know you said not,
there's never a case where everyone can
be happy. But what do you see as
being the major problems from having,
I guess widespread consensus?
President Jalal Talabani: Yeah, the major
problems was first the relation
between state and religion. Some people
say, insisted that Iraq must be an
Islamic regime, and some people wanted
to say that Islam is the main source of
the laws in Iraq. It was one of the big
shifts in the discussion. Second was,
some Sunni Arabs refuse consideration
for the South. They recognize a
federation for Kurdistan because they
said federation is existing since a long time
in Kurdistan. It is a reality to de facto.
But they denied right of having original
government for the people of the South.
The third, about the relation between
Iraq and Arab World. What we have agreed
with the secretary-general of Arab
League was Iraq is a founding member,
enacted member of the League of Arab
Leagues, and committed to the charter
and the decisions of Arab League. Some
people want to say that Iraq as a part
of Arab nation, by denying the existence of
Kurds, Kurdanians, Turkomans, Assyrians,
etcetera. That was the three main
issues
in the way of reaching a consensus on the
Constitution.
Lee Bollinger: Yes.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: Mr. President, my name
is Hallah Al-Zaraf. I am an Iraqi
Fulbright student. I major in health
policy, and if you allow me sir, I will speak
in English, and then give me the pleasure
of talking in Arabic to our president. As
an Iraqi Arab Muslim Shi'a woman, I feel
so privileged to stand here and talk to
you because this is the first time I have
a chance to talk a president and I have
passed my 40 years. I never wanted to
speak to the president before, but I am
greatly honored to be here and talk to
you. I'm doing masters, I left a family
behind. I'm doing it basically for Iraq.
I want to go back as soon as possible and
try to do something and participate with
all the good efforts. I have the worry,
being a woman, being, you know, I don't
know what's going to happen to the
Constitution, the draft, but I do acknowledge
that there are women leadership. I
mean, the existence of the First Lady
here is something we would have never
thought it would happen, and the lady
minister.
How can we be-- (applause) what assurances
could we have in light of what you
have said about the dominance of the cleric,
very strong fundamental attitude
towards women participation in Iraq? What
is our assurance if we go back? And
thank you very much. I don't know if I
need to it in Arabic. (speaks Arabic)
President Jalal Talabani: Well, I am,
no, no, I am, I'm proud to have you with
us here, an Iraqi woman from Shi'ite section
of Iraq, and proud to, to see lady like
you express this attitude very frankly.
And I'd like to tell you that according in
institution, many rights of women is insured.
Equality among men and women.
The right to have 25 person of Parliament
from women. Of course this will reflect
in government. Now we have about six ministers,
ladies. Six ladies ministers in
the--we'll have the (inaudible) prime
minister, a lady also. And we have many
members in the, ladies in the National
Assembly. And also, we indirectly put in
the Constitution that this Constitution
will respect the universal declaration of
human rights, which it had a lot of rights
of women in it. And also, the women are
free to choose in their marriage and their
divorce, unlikely divorce of course to
choose if they want to go to Civil Court
or to go to the mosque.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: One more last thing,
please allow me to ask--
President Jalal Talabani: And of course,
you know, my dear sister, you know
that in Iraq we have now a strong movement,
but I must be honest with you, they
are not denying the fundamental rights
of women. There are some kinds of
differences, as you know.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: Yes. And this is, this
is the worry.
President Jalal Talabani: But we are trying
to receive compromise on it.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: And *sha Allah, He will
succeed. Thank you very much.
President Jalal Talabani: We will do.
Thank you.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: And please accept the
great greetings from other Iraqi
Fulbrighters who are studying in Texas,
Massachusetts, Michigan, this is a great
opportunity to be here and talk to you
personally.
President Jalal Talabani: Give all of
them regards--
Hallah Al-Zaraf: Thank you very much.
President Jalal Talabani: --and my love.
Hallah Al-Zaraf: Thank you very much,
Mr. President. (applause)
Lee Bollinger: The, the president has
time for just two more questions. Yes?
Emil Rove: My name is Emil Rove. I am
an International Undergraduate
Student in Columbia College. Mr. President,
it is known that you have distanced
yourself from the Kurdish Independence
Movement for the sake of working with
different ethnic groups during the process
of rebuilding Iraq. What I am
wondering is what your standards are going
to be in the future concerning the
Kurdish Independence Movement.
President Jalal Talabani: Well, my dear
friend. I had my struggle all my life, I
was struggling for democracy in Iraq and
Kurdish rights within the framework of
Iraq. I was convinced that Kurdish people,
who forcibly divided in the Middle
East, has the right to serve this nation
like others. But, it's impossible today to
think about independent Kurdistan. I never
asked for independent Kurdistan
because I know it's impossible to--I can
give you one example now. Let us
imagine, tomorrow, the National Assembly
of Kurdistan decides declaring
independence, if our neighbors don't fight
us, but close the border, how it can
come back to you again to be here in this
presence. For example, we must be
realistic. We must struggle for what is
possible, achievable of the mass of
Kurdish people, and rethink the best is
democracy for Iraq and federation within
the framework of Iraq as a part of Kurdistan
also. Thank you very much.
Lee Bollinger: Yes?
Crystal Foray: President. Thank you for
coming today. My name is Crystal
Foray, and I'm a graduate student at the
School of Social Work, concentrating in
International Social Welfare. In your
speech, you said that there was no specific
time frame to pull the troops out of Iraq.
So my question for you is in your
opinion, what exactly would need to take
place in order for our troops to come
home? Thank you.
President Jalal Talabani: I think the
best thing we can do is that to train our
forces and to prepare Iraqi Armed Forces
for combating against terrorism and
defending this sovereignty independent
of the country. And of course, there
must be always a kind of consultation
and negotiation among coalition forces in
Iraqi to reach agreement when it will
be necessary to remove. But I think when
anyone's starting a noble mission, it
must be finished successfully. Thank you
very much.
Lee Bollinger: Mr. President, let me just
say that it is a great pleasure and
honor for us to have you here today and
to spend this time. It is interesting.
We're working on a project as part of
the World Leaders' Forum to have women
from the Iraqi legislature come and speak
at Columbia at some point in this year.
This, of course, with the issues that
have been raised, speak to great questions
in the United States and the world, issues
of multilateralism, issues of
democracy, issues of free markets, issues
of intelligence. These are questions
that are being debated throughout America
at this time, as you know. For you to
come here and spend this time with us
and to answer questions so forthrightly
and freely, we deeply appreciate it, and
thank you all for coming to join us.
President Jalal Talabani: Thank you, Mr.
President. (applause) You are very
kind. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.